let's have a go of this the previous
question we tackled it before we went to
the visuals by play our log boys that's
a smart move you should absolutely do
that wherever you can okay so how would
you do it here
what can you not look at use great we
can use our power law this too right I
can bring it out the front and I should
be able to say this okay
now this this looks just like this
except it's a different scale factor
okay so what's it gonna look like I've
still got this same vertical asymptote x
equals zero right I'm still gonna get
this general shape I'm still going to
have and in step one but instead of my
point being two three my point will be
two - okay good so there we go
so far Swigert it's not wrong by the way
like that graph should be there I'm just
kind of missing something it's kind of
missing something significant now the
question is where is the missing piece
that looks time to me I don't see any
missing pitch okay
to help you understand what's going on
I'll bring you back up here you remember
last lesson we're trio situations right
and we said okay we said if we have
something like this
then the restriction here is that this
guy needs to be positive you care with
that that's all of it now if this is
positive then what I have over here is x
squared and I want that to be positive
tell me when is x squared
you know what X Quinn was like when is x
squared positive answer and so all real
values of X except
corrects equal zero yeah right now what
that means is I'll stand it oh and like
for this guy we didn't write it because
it's kind of self-evident on the ground
this guy in the restriction here doesn't
apply over here or rather it applies
with a bit of difference you can get
negative values or you can get positive
values because when you throw them in
they're gonna get squared right and so
if I put in you know minus 2 okay this
is gonna be log base 2 off what's minus
2 squared it's gonna be full log base 2
a 4 I'll still get this value up here
right so I am missing at least women I'm
missing exactly half my graph I'm
missing this now be careful it's not too
bad because I've got to party right and
they are meant to be reflections of each
other across that y-axis there really
ought to be at the same point right and
now I have two branches I want to have
two points for scale
so by the way when we're making
excitement right we we said this we went
from line 1 to line 2
and that's kind of true but how can we
fix up line 2 because lunch is either
missing that piece that we just drew in
chocolate just likes you so it's
actually correct and actually what I
graph okay now one suggestion is to put
this okay and it certainly seems like
like I want two pots right and it's kind
of like taking a square root there is an
issue though with cleaner Fussel - you
because remember this way what's that
plus or minus actually modifying what's
it changing and the answer is it's even
though it's over here it's really
changing the Y can you see that it's
actually quite I mean in in sort of
broad terms it's quite far away from the
X which is nestled all the way inside
there right so even though plus or minus
two long term X is going to be an
interesting graph it's not gonna be this
graph in fact it will be this graph
because I've got the puzzle one and I
flipped it vertically right now which by
the way is no longer functional is it
it's a relation yeah sure okay let me
let me slow down so this is 2 log base 2
of X now regular one but if I have plus
or minus that I'm gonna have the flipped
version flipped vertically than
vertically because that plus or minus is
really over here on the Y even though it
looks like it's on the right-hand side
what's really changing is the black so
it's very cool okay and you guys can see
that if this was the question I gave you
if this was the question I gave you can
you see the restriction X X is still our
regular old positive right I'm still I'm
still on this side of the axis but I
flipped around okay yes okay think
you're not unlimited so therefore
therefore to fix this right what would I
put on there
okay yeah Jitsu pthew yes yes that's
exactly what I would do now are you two
things okay
I could I could define it for two
different like a piggy side and for a
positive side okay
but because I've got the boundary being
x equals zero that's going to change
during off I can do this in one fell
swoop I can just say that can you see
that this achieves what I wanted to
achieve okay
I'm it's better than plus or minus and
then putting the restrictions on because
Daniel X that's been a mess really I
already have something which essentially
just says give me the positive value
thank you nope no because this isn't
making Y positive if it's making the x
value positive right so when I slap in -
to just go through the process it'll be
to log base two of it'll become positive
- okay which is going to give you this
value of U we're not changing it we just
take into account all the different
parts that you get from it okay now this
absolute value of X especially as it
applies to logs he will come back when
we look at differentiation integration
you just you just sort of makes me file
it away okay right on first
Thanks putting a square root here like
that you could but then you'd have to
say where you want those to apply right
like you'd have to have the piecemeal
thing you'd have to tell you this one
for expend 0 this 1 for X investors do
you know
yes yes in case you catch that right if
this power appears two or four or six or
eight okay then actually it doesn't
matter what the sine of X is you can
throw them in and it will work just fine
which means essentially yes you can put
an absolute value in there okay I
wouldn't memorize that as a rule for two
reasons number one you're not frequently
going to encounter are the values of X
but it still works it does work like if
I had changed it to a four then it would
be full log base two and then yeah you
would get precise yeah that's that's
exactly right you see this I could
rewrite like this and if I put a
negative into X Q to be negative break
the law which is why yes but it's worth
noting it's worth it before I leave off
that just because you monthly took that
step and I'm if I had given you if I
given you this right this does not turn
into this but it doesn't magically get
bird science okay because I haven't said
its swear look at the restriction on
this look at the restriction in the form
that I give it to you it's still this
restriction and it's been stretched it's
only when I tell you this should be
squared that's when the restriction
changes